[Música]
el 2 de mayo del 2002 tuvo lugar en la
pequeña población de bojayá en el
departamento de chocó en la selva del
pacífico colombiano uno de los capítulos
más lamentables de la historia de ese
país los hechos ocurrieron cuando esta
población de unos nueve mil habitantes
quedó en medio del fuego cruzado entre
integrantes de la ahora extinta
guerrilla de las farc y paramilitares de
las autodefensas unidas de colombia
conocidas como av se en el punto álgido
del combate la guerrilla lanzó un
cilindro-bomba contra los paramilitares
que cayó en la iglesia del pueblo en
donde buena parte de sus habitantes se
había refugiado la explosión dejó 86
muertos entre ellos varios adultos
menores de edad y ancianos otras cifras
estiman que fueron entre 102 y 119 las
víctimas lo cierto es que los habitantes
de bojayá intentaron ponerse a salvo
defenderse en total soledad porque el
ejército y el estado colombiano no
pudieron garantizarles uno de los puntos
más básicos de la constitución de ese
país la seguridad dos décadas después
organizaciones nacionales e
internacionales de derechos humanos como
por ejemplo el sistema integral para la
paz la iglesia católica del choco la
oficina en colombia de la alta
comisionada de las naciones unidas para
los derechos humanos y la consultoría
para los derechos humanos y el
desplazamiento alertan que los
habitantes de este municipio están
nuevamente expuestos a violaciones de
los derechos humanos y ante una posible
nueva tragedia
estas organizaciones afirman que la
población de bojayá ha denunciado
homicidios amenazas ataques
reclutamiento forzado de menores
desplazamiento forzado confinamientos
restricciones a la movilidad
desapariciones forzadas y violaciones
tanto estos organismos como también la
población civil piden para atender esta
situación que haya una presencia
integral del estado colombiano también
la reparación colectiva de las víctimas
implementación plena del acuerdo de paz
garantías de los derechos económicos
sociales y culturales de la población
búsqueda de las personas desaparecidas y
el desmantelamiento de los grupos
armados no estatales
porque le cuesta tanto al estado
colombiano hacer presencia en zonas
remotas y garantizar la seguridad de sus
ciudadanos al día de hoy porque sigue
costando tanto la implementación del
acuerdo de paz particularmente en estas
zonas apartadas en donde hubo fuertes
enfrentamientos y fueron escenarios de
los años más difíciles de la guerra en
colombia que dicen hoy en día los
habitantes de esta población de una
población como bojayá que dice el
gobierno 20 años después que dicen los
integrantes de la entonces guerrilla de
las farc hoy en el debate de france 24
20 años de la masacre de bojayá persiste
la violencia 20 años de impunidad para
analizar este tema hemos invitado a
nadie vargas ella es investigadora y
analista en temas de seguridad y
violencia
organizada también está con nosotros
camilo gonzález él es presidente del
instituto de estudios para el desarrollo
y la paz indepaz
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
pueden participar en este debate o en
este análisis con sus comentarios y sus
preguntas lo pueden hacer a través de
nuestras redes sociales no se encuentran
en facebook en twitter y también en
instagram estamos como franz 4
sant y luego que es mi cuenta personal
les recuerdo que la etiqueta es numeral
el debate efe 24 esperamos todos sus
comentarios y preguntas en torno a este
tema y comienzo entonces con nuestra
invitada dándole la bienvenida del
programa a nadie' vargas gracias por
estar con nosotros nadie y 20 años ha
pasado desde que ocurrió esta masacre en
la población de bojayá en colombia que
elecciones dejó este hecho tan doloroso
para los colombianos que dejó para el
estado colombiano para la población y
para la historia de este país
buenas tardes a todos ya todos los que
nos están viendo los 24 gracias por la
invitación
qué lección es que yo creo que digamos a
nivel país hay un gran aprendizaje sobre
la necesidad de
o más bien un llamado sobre la relación
que existe entre la paz la seguridad y
la reconciliación
quiero pensar lo que lo que decía el
estado y lo que decían las comunidades y
lo que decían organizaciones de la
sociedad civil justo hace 20 años al
respecto de lo que ocurría en el
territorio y
sin ir en detrimento de la gravedad de
lo que ocurrió en ese momento y de la
masacre y un poco las voces resuenan de
manera similar en las comunidades
exigiendo al estado
la presencia integral pero un énfasis en
la garantía de seguridad una cosa que
hoy 20 años después se repite
el estado con una voz de indiferencia
hace menos de un mes el ministro del
interior daniel palacios decía que la
denuncia sobre violencia en chico eran
extravagantes entonces nuevamente hay
ahí una negligencia de parte del
ejecutivo por atender la situación del
choco
pero paralelo hay otras voces incluso
del estado que alertan sobre la gravedad
está la defensoría del pueblo anunciando
nuevamente los riesgos que hoy que hoy
tienen en las comunidades por la
presencia del nn y la disputa que tienen
con las fases de
ésta la procuraduría está también en el
alto comisionado para
los buenos para naciones unidas
nuevamente alertando sobre los riesgos
de desplazamiento los concilia miento
reclutamiento entonces siento como que
es un déjà vú muy muy desolador lo que
lo que está ocurriendo hoy si pensamos
visible años atrás un deja vú 20 años
después le doy la bienvenida a nuestro
otro invitado camilo gonzález también
está en la ciudad de bogotá camilo
bienvenido y elecciones deja 20 años
después esta masacre de bojayá en el
departamento de chocó ya lo decía nadie
es el escenario actual es como la
especie de déjà vú qué lecciones deja y
qué impresiones tiene usted
buen día en muchas lecciones podríamos
comenzar diciendo que allí se presentó
una clara situación de violación del
derecho humanitario cuando se hay un
enfrentamiento utilizando como parapeto
a la población y sin preocuparse por las
consecuencias sobre ellas los
paramilitares se colocaron detrás de la
iglesia y la guerrilla en su
enfrentamiento
continúa atacando a pesar de que estaba
allí en la iglesia estaba la población
esto es una situación que se repite se
repite cuando se considera que los
civiles en medio de la confrontación no
son la prioridad y se siguen presentando
situaciones en las cuales son tomados
civiles como rehenes o en momentos en
los cuales hay civiles en medio de gente
armada otros consideran que es legítimo
para atacar a unos enemigos y producir
bajas entre la población civil es decir
es una lesión que no se aprendió yo creo
que son más las lesiones no aprendidas
se tiene una verdad parcial la verdad ha
comenzado la comisión de esclarecimiento
la jefe hay reconocimiento de
responsabilidad por parte de las farc
pero estamos todavía acumulando puntos
puros en este en este tema lo mismo que
en justicia es una situación que a esta
altura tampoco hay reparación porque no
se ve que la reparación tiene que ver
con tiene que tener transformaciones no
puede ser y el perdón y la
reconciliación no son palabras que se
describan las víctimas o declaraciones
superficiales de los victimarios
si hay que haber atrás acciones
fundamentales en los territorios
estamos viendo estas alertas de nuevas
amenazas para el territorio para la
población es porque las lecciones no
fueron del todo aprendidas hago la ronda
a la inversa continúo con camilo ya le
doy la palabra a nadie hace 20 años
veíamos como usted lo dice en un
escenario similar alertas en total
fueron 7 alertas las que fueron emitidas
por la atención que había en esta zona y
por el peligro que corría la población
porque el ejército colombiano no actúa
porque las autoridades civiles no
actuaron porque no se dio la atención
necesaria dos días después de la masacre
aparecieron las autoridades civiles y
cuatro días después llegó el ejército
camilo porque no actuaran
la verdad porque en ese periodo nosotros
teníamos una prioridad desde el estado
que era el combate a la guerrilla la
lucha contrainsurgente entonces era
legítimo cualquier tipo de alianzas en
ese periodo se dio una gran alianza en
el país entre agentes del estado agentes
de la fuerza pública otros estamentos y
paramilitares
por eso hay testimonios de circulación
de paramilitares en esas en esas zonas
tiene una presencia del estado eso
digamos que ha habido concepciones
doctrinas que no han permitido la
diligencia desde desde la acción del
estado para proteger a la población pero
creo que procedió a eso por otro lado yo
creo que también el tipo de estrategias
de la guerrilla de las farc que llevó a
la destrucción desde muchas comunidades
en latakia poblaciones en varios
departamentos donde atacan para atacar
estaciones de policía o enfrentamientos
con la policía lo hacían en medio de los
cascos urbanos es decir que se
desarrolló toda una práctica
cercana pues a la promoción de crímenes
de lesa humanidad de violaciones al
derecho humanitario y desafortunadamente
en una desatención a las alertas
tempranas aquí ha habido omisión ha
habido complicidades hoy
autoridades muy importantes especiales
del departamento del choco comunidades
alertan sobre eso si no existen ciudades
y omisiones de modo que yo creo que son
no solamente los comportamientos de los
ilegales son también la falta de
compromiso y diligencia de quienes deben
velar por la protección y la vida de la
gente
nadie recordemos que la audiencia que
este programa va más allá de las
fronteras colombianas para muchas
personas este será un hecho del que por
primera vez están oyendo o del que
tienen pocos datos nos ve gente a lo
largo y ancho de todo el continente
latinoamericano creo que valdría la pena
explicarle a la audiencia fuera de
colombia cuál es el contexto del
departamento del choco cómo es la
realidad de estos municipios chocoanos y
cómo era la realidad de bojayá hace 20
años es una zona selvática en el
pacífico colombiano en el occidente del
país pero como es esta zona de ese país
bueno entonces el departamento del choco
está ubicado en el litoral pacífico
colombiano
y tiene efectivamente una geografía o
unas características biofísicas que
implican cierta complejidad para la
conectividad con el resto del país yoko
tiene es un departamento
fundamentalmente selvático de tal manera
que allí construir vías es muy costoso
pero el estado no se la ha jugado por
utilizar los ríos que son
todos digamos como que todo el choco
está conectado a través de ríos y
cuerpos acuíferos que permitirían la
movilidad pero digamos ha habido una
falta de voluntad por pensar otras
formas de conectividad
con el país e incluso dentro del
departamento estamos hablando de que los
cascos urbanos pueden quedar a 34 horas
5 horas 12 horas de los corregimientos
en donde están las comunidades
más allá del conflicto armado casi que
confinadas por la dificultad de
conectarse en la cotidianidad y hablamos
de cosas muy básicas como alimentación
salud saneamiento
etcétera entonces ese definitivamente es
un reto pero eso ha sido una digamos una
excusa una justificación por parte del
estado para no garantizar otra serie de
servicios y sobre todo también para no
hacer una avería juiciosa del dinero
estatal que allí se debería invertir
el choco no es un departamento pobre
chico tiene recursos sin embargo el
chico también el departamento como tal
cuenta con una clase política
absolutamente extra y yo aquí
menoscabado todos los recursos públicos
en temas de corrupción y en su momento
digamos también hubo alianzas con grupos
paramilitares para asegurar el control
territorial y
aparte de eso
no es menor
hay un tema que es muy particular y es
la presencia fuertísima de comunidades
afrodescendientes e indígenas que en
colombia tienen
la posibilidad de darse el gobierno en
términos territoriales son territorios
especiales resguardos y comunidades
indígenas claro que implica también
otras otras otras formas que respeten
las diferencias
étnicas de las comunidades entonces son
literalmente cuanto apartamento complejo
compleja la situación
camilo en hace 20 años hace dos décadas
entendemos de la complejidad geofísica
de este de este departamento selvático
con una infraestructura muy deficiente
pero que hace particular esta zona donde
estaba bojayá
en particular esta zona para que incluso
hoy en día sigue siendo un territorio
disputado por grupos delincuenciales por
otros grupos guerrilleros que están
actuando hoy en día en colombia
porque es importante este corredor
porque es importante esta ruta es
tránsito de narcotráfico es en qué punto
estamos hablando a nivel estratégico
bueno como como estaba dicho este
departamento la totalidad del
departamento es propiedad colectiva de
comunidades afrodescendientes de
resguardos indígenas y también está
conformada por zonas de reserva forestal
pero hay ha habido una disputa por el
oro que viene desde la época de la
colonia y en una época fue el principal
rincón de producción de oro de todos de
todo colombia y sigue siendo de gran
riqueza aurífera toda la cuenca del
atrato y además como está cerca y
comunicado intercomunicador no solamente
por mar citó por los ríos con panamá
también es una ruta muy privilegiada
para el tráfico de personas para el
tráfico de armas el tráfico de cocaína y
también territorio en disputa porque hay
sectores que quieren la tierra de las
comunidades negras entonces utilizan la
violencia y el desplazamiento para luego
después ir por las tierras que son de
propiedad colectiva que son de propiedad
ancestral
tituladas por constitución algunas
comunidades
consejos comunitarios de comunidad
entendida y los resguardos indígenas
entonces eso sigue presente es una
guerra por recursos la que ha habido en
el departamento y una guerra además
racista porque es en contra de
poblaciones étnicas que han sido
marginalizadas excluidas y que sus
territorios son apetecidos labor legal
es legal' es el negocio de la madera por
ejemplo ha sido fundamentalmente ilegal
son millones y millones de dólares los
que están forman parte de ese negocio
como los del oro
tal vez se puede equiparar el negocio
ilegal del oro de la madera al negocio
de la cocaína o la trata de personas
entonces hay una disputa por los
territorios los armados no son más que
los instrumentos de intereses de poder y
de intereses económicos que van en trate
estos territorios de modo que yo creo
que es el transfondo por eso veinte años
después habiendo asumido el acuerdo de
paz
esperando que eso nos conduzca el
posconflicto tenemos un territorio donde
el mayor número de desplazados y
confinados en en el último periodo
tenemos en este departamento las cifras
mayores en evitar el basílico tenemos el
80 por ciento del desplazamiento y
confinamiento que se registra en los
últimos años y con ese panorama nadie
con ese entendiendo ya la importancia de
este territorio y la complejidad de lo
que se vivía allí se suma un factor muy
importante que tal vez resulta complejo
para entender también desde fuera de
colombia y es esa incapacidad del estado
colombiano de hacer presencia no
solamente el choco hay zonas incluso muy
cercanas a bogotá la capital o la zona
andina de colombia que es tal vez la
zona donde se concentra la mayor parte
de la población donde hay mucha
deficiencia de la presencia del estado
porque al estado colombiano le ha
costado no solo ahora a lo largo de su
historia hacer presencia en la totalidad
del territorio nacional
yo creo que hallaría una salvedad y no
es que no haga presencia hace presencia
de manera diferenciada
y creo que no es necesariamente un
asunto de incapacidad lo pondría más
bien en términos de voluntad política el
estado colombiano se construyó de una
manera muy particular y es que funcionó
a partir de acuerdos entre élites
locales en los departamentos con élites
del centro que gobiernan digamos en
términos nacionales entonces se ha
mantenido si se quiere esa forma de
administrar el territorio en el cual el
estado central no se mete con los
territorios que son gobernados por
élites políticas locales que han
gobernado de alguna manera de manera
como digo extractiva corrupta
y ese es un poco el arreglo que hay si
se quiere político pensemos lo en
términos analíticos ya en términos
reales cómo se ve eso
en la falta de voluntad política
realmente el tema de como tú lo decías
no sólo tiene que ver con la geografía
un poco indómito en chocó sino vamos a
ver un poco aquí en el entorno del
centro y es que el estado llega en
términos de militares llega en términos
de fuerza pública llega en términos del
cobro de ciertos impuestos pero no llega
en términos de la institucionalidad que
se requeriría para mantener digamos
unas condiciones mínimas de dignidad y
de
justicia y convivencia no sólo tienen
que ver con la falta de infraestructura
para educación para salud para
saneamiento sino también la falta
infraestructura para administración de
justicia resolución pacífica de
conflictos entonces creo que pero
siempre en todo el lado vas a encontrar
militares entonces creo que hay ahí una
una visión que que demuestra un poco que
el estado si puede llegar lo que pasa es
que hay un arreglo político que es muy
complicado desentrañar
y es cómo hacer para que quienes
gobiernan el nivel central quieran y
tengan el interés de ir a gobernar en
los territorios más periféricos o los
territorios que no son el centro del
país y es una realidad que no solamente
se ve en el pacífico sino también en el
oriente colombiano camilo en
recientemente fue dado a conocer que
esta masacre de el municipio de bojayá
del corregimiento de bojayá entrara a
ser parte de la jurisdicción especial
para la paz la gp sería de esta forma
entonces la primera masacre investigada
por esta justicia transicional esto qué
significa para éste para este hecho
puntual para llevar justicia después de
20 años y que quienes son culpables
deban presentarse ante las autoridades
como debe ser como lo han esperado los
familiares de las víctimas de esta
masacre
la jurisdicción especial para la paz ha
abierto lo que llaman un nuevo macro
caso en el tema étnico y tiene como una
referencia muy importante precisamente
estos territorios eso se completa con un
macro caso regional para la región de
urabá porque son son zonas que están muy
interconectadas y con problemas
similares
es una buena noticia que después de 20
años se tenga una ruta de justicia de
justicia transicional en la web y
esperemos que también el informe está
próximo a salir pero la comisión de la
verdad que nos hagan aportes en el
capítulo que haya anunciado el problemas
territoriales y que tiene que ver con
casos tan
emblemático de lo que ha sido del horror
en colombia como el de bojayá de modo
que yo creo que sí vamos a tener esa esa
investigación especial de lage que creo
que tendrán resultados esto no va a ser
automático pero yo creo que en unos
cuatro años si hacemos un buen cálculo
tendremos un informe ya con sentencia
con sanciones por parte de la gente en
el caso de hoja ya lo que ha habido
durante todo este período ha sido
impunidad a veces que el sistema de
justicia y paz y la justicia de la
fiscalía ni ningún nuestros órganos pues
ha avanzado
en tomar decisiones de responsabilidad
tanto los actores inmediatos del hecho
en este caso la responsabilidad directa
de parte de las farc que ahora están
pues en manos del
jefe
los responsables por omisión que tienen
que ver con las habilidades del estado
en este caso
nació justamente en camilo ya empieza a
tocar la siguiente pregunta que le
quería hacer a usted y es el papel y los
culpables en todo está en toda esta
masacre
leyendo varios informes se habla que ha
habido como una especie de
discriminación de la culpabilidad de los
actores que están involucrados en este
hecho y prácticamente gran parte de la
culpa recayó en la guerrilla de las farc
por haber disparado ese cilindro bomba
que
explotó en la iglesia del corregimiento
pero también aquí hay que hablar de
otros actores en este en este como en
esta confrontación estaban también los
las autodefensas y pues también está el
estado colombiano
están desequilibradas las cargas de
culpabilidad que culpabilidad debe
asumir cada una de estas partes
involucradas como lo ve usted
a ver que digamos en colombia y como ya
lo decía camilo el tema de seguridad
vive ahí un poco el de derechos humanos
ha tenido un fuerte énfasis en las
acciones en las violaciones a los
derechos humanos y al derecho
internacional humanitario cometidas por
las guerrillas eso es indiscutible y el
respecto digamos
diferentes organizaciones y el estado ha
logrado un nivel si se quiere
esclarecimiento importante para nadie es
un secreto que las farc fue quien hizo
eso y lo reconoció hoy es sabido sin
embargo se ha explorado mucho menos en
términos de la responsabilidad de otros
actores y del estado y creo que ese
sería como en términos de aporte a la
verdad y esclarecimiento y lo novedoso
más allá digamos de lo que pueda decir
las fas respecto a modos superando
intereses actores el transfondo de de
esto y pensando un poco en el relato de
los hechos que no es menor y que tú
mencionaste al comienzo del programa
más o menos fueron 8 alertas tempranas
que emitió la defensoría del pueblo que
es la entidad un poco encargada de la
veeduría de los derechos humanos
alertando porque así de hecho se llama
alerta alertando al estado sobre lo que
venía ocurriendo allí y eso no fue un
mes antes ni días antes la defensoría
del pueblo así como naciones unidas y
así como en las organizaciones de
derechos humanos local y la diócesis que
choco ha tenido un rol muy importante
desde octubre del año anterior es decir
desde 2001 estuvieron alertando al
estado sobre la avanzada de los
paramilitares y ahí entra un tema que es
muy muy muy central
del que se empieza a hablar y es cuál ha
sido realmente la relación entre la
fuerza pública y los paramilitares y por
qué los paramilitares permitir porque el
ejército permitió el avanzada de
paramilitares en territorio en
detrimento de los derechos de la
población entonces creo que más allá va
a decir el estado omitió
porque pensaría se podría pensar que fue
solamente en el evento el estado
realmente duró meses meses ignorando las
alertas
ignorando no solamente era como un
evento sorpresa o un asunto de fuerza
pública sino un tema que tenía encima la
visión de otras entidades también del
estado que estaban diciendo necesitamos
de la fuerza pública son del sector
seguridad acá y el sector seguridad no
atendió entonces creo que ahí está
también parte de
del relato que no se ha contado en
colombia y que hoy podría también y
aplica para hoy 20 años después que nos
expliquen porque que le explica de las
comunidades porque si si hay alertas y
hay información comprobada si hay
estudios si hay pruebas de los riesgos
tan importantes es que está viendo bien
un lugar en el escritorio porque el
estado no lo atiende por haber estado
deja de aprender y deja de cumplir con
su con sus deberes con su
responsabilidad vamos llegando ya al
bloque final del programa camilo y estas
alertas de las que hemos hablado y que
vuelve a mencionar nadie en su última
respuesta me lleva a él hoy por hoy el
día el presente y estamos en un
escenario similar los lo hemos hablado
ya a lo largo del programa que se puede
hacer para evitar entonces una situación
similar o que se presenta algún tipo de
violencia en esta en esta comunidad en
el txoko
dado que ya han hecho varias denuncias
de diferentes violaciones de los
derechos humanos está otra vez el estado
colombiano quedándose un poco en las
sombras y con poca capacidad de acción
como se puede evitar
pues el asunto es que no está no estamos
ante el pronóstico de una situación de
violencia sino que estamos ante el
proceso ya con una situación de agresión
a esta comunidad incluso en bojayá en la
zona en la pequeña cabecera municipal y
en las zonas aledañas el control lo está
ejerciendo el llamado clan del golfo un
grupo narcoparamilitar que opera no
solamente en ese municipio sino en 150
municipios más y que ha estado en esas
zonas ejerciendo su control y ahora está
en pugna con el ejército de liberación
nacional en la misma zona
es decir en esta zona de bojayá entonces
esta parte del atrato
medio y bajo atrato también hacer río
san juan en toda la región se está en la
gran disputa y esto está produciendo
consecuencias impresionantes el hecho de
que una niña de 6 años se haya suicidado
a la semana pasada
por el temor y la angustia alrededor de
estos temas y del posible reclutamiento
de menores esto es parte de una cadena
llevamos 50 suicidios en niños y jóvenes
por el temor al reclutamiento forzado
por parte de estos grupos esto reclama
por supuesto otro tipo de presencia del
estado no simplemente presencia militar
consejos de seguridad
reuniones de ofrecimiento de recompensas
siendo yo creo que son muchas acciones
comenzando por la célula una verdadera
revisión de la situación interna de las
propias fuerzas y la presencia del
estado de las fuerzas armadas allí para
que no quede ninguna duda frente a las
denuncias que han hecho jerarquía de la
iglesia y comunidades que hay
complicidades no puede haber ningún tipo
de tolerancia y eso tiene que tener
claridad credibilidad para que se genere
confianza y lo que está dicho y respeto
a la autonomía de las comunidades no se
trata de que llegue a gobernar al estado
ejerciendo verticalmente sus designios
sino que se reconozca que son pueblos en
son comunidades que tienen que tener una
relativa autonomía que deben
fortalecerse justicia propia que debe
haber un manejo desde adentro de los que
son las visiones de planes de vida es de
desarrollo y reconocer realmente se
trata de territorios especiales ebro que
sobresale en un sitio y no territorios
para una nueva colonización porque es
que la violencia está desde el propio
planteamiento institucional que
considera estos como territorios
salvajes que pueden ser objeto de una
recolonización al servicio de grandes
proyectos clave grupo scripts
vamos llegando ya a la parte final del
programa nadie me interesa conocer su
opinión sobre esta forma cómo se puede
evitar otros hechos de violencia que ya
están alertadas diferentes organismos
internacionales y nacionales por los
hechos que han ocurrido en los últimos
días cómo poder evitar algo similar a lo
que ocurrió en bohai hace 20 años
bueno pues ya con la firma del acuerdo
final y con la negociación con las farc
creo que se abrió nuevamente
una conversación sobre las veces y las
condiciones que se requieren en los
territorios para construir paz y aquí
digamos había una conversación sobre la
idea de paz completa o pas total y
claramente la situación de violencia en
el txoko es un
reciclaje de los factores que venían
siendo digamos hace 20 años los que
promovían
esta situación entonces tenemos grupos
armados esta ln y esta valla clan del
golfo la sages
con el l n y creo que cuando los grupos
armados se ha demostrado que no existe
la capacidad del estado y no es viable
ganar en términos militares hay que
abrir negociación y eso se puede hacer
con el l n el gobierno del ex presidente
santos dejó en las condiciones sobre la
mesa para la posibilidad de que esta
guerrilla transite a la legalidad y
haces una medida absolutamente necesaria
segundo sometimiento a la justicia por
parte de los grupos criminales una
camino que también el ex presidente
comenzó a recorrer con esa organización
y que ve este gobierno ambos a ambos
escenarios él le cerró la puerta pero
que hoy digamos es necesario
contemplarlo chile tercero la
participación de las comunidades como lo
hemos dicho en este programa existe la
particularidad de que son comunidades
negras e indígenas que tiene autonomía
de gobierno territorial y que una
y normalización o estabilización de los
territorios no se puede hacer al margen
de las de su cultura y de su idea de paz
y de reconciliación tercero el tema
imbert estatal y ahí el tema de vendría
porque los recursos que van hacia los
departamentos se los roban entonces en
ghana resulta que los recursos que se
despiden allá que se implementen en
condiciones en garantizar las
condiciones sociales y en este punto
creo que el acuerdo final con el
capítulo étnico de la cuarta final con
las farc o en el capítulo étnico dejó
sentadas las bases para eso lines y
santiago sería como una cuarta un cuarto
elemento necesario y es la
implementación del acuerdo de paz sin
embargo parece que esto es como una
especie de círculo vicioso que no
termina de salir y el gobierno en el
país está de esta espiral de violencia
me quedaba un par de minutos para
finalizar el programa le pregunto a los
dos para que me respondan muy puntual
por las víctimas que ha sido de la vida
de ellos estas personas fueron obligadas
a retirarse de sus zonas
donde tradicionalmente sus etnias
habitaron durante muchos años que ha
hecho el gobierno por ellas en donde se
encuentran en estos momentos camino
pues la verdad que lo que tenemos es un
proceso de re victimización
porque han dicho las propias comunidades
las víctimas en estos días es que
todavía están a la espera de la
reparación de dos repetición e incluso
que hubo que esperar 17 años para que
les entregaran identificados los restos
de los familiares a 72 de ellos nosotros
están pendientes ni siquiera podido
hacer un duelo es real sobre lo que
aconteció entonces yo creo que las
víctimas están esperando verdad justicia
reparación la implementación del acuerdo
de paz en su integralidad pero que es la
ruta lo que está reclamando la gente y
que se entienda que la reconciliación y
el perdón no es algo que simplemente se
soluciona con que se haga un evento es
simbólico sino que se requiere
transformaciones efectivas en los
territorios con la implementación de los
acuerdos de paz así me queda un minuto
para finalizar el programa quiero
preguntarle que tanto ha perdonado
colombia a la sociedad colombiana
la antigua guerrilla de las farc que es
la guerrilla a la que se le acusa de
haber perpetrado esta masacre en bojayá
que tanto ha comenzado a sanar la
sociedad colombiana después de la firma
del acuerdo de paz
a ver yo ahí tengo tengo una idea sobre
el perdón y es que el perdón el perdón
es político el perdón no es en abstracto
es una cosa que el que la víctima
entrega pero en términos de proceso de
paz y de nación es un asunto político
eso es un asunto que tiene que ver con
la verdad con la justicia con la
reparación
y la justicia está allá en el centro tú
no puedes perdonar si no te han pedido
perdón y yo creo que las farc ha
caminado en ese en esa ruta
sin embargo pienso que el conflicto con
silvia no ha sido mucho más complejo y
hoy las víctimas saben que las farc
claro son responsables de una serie de
hechos pero que se necesita mucho más
allá de la
de los eventos públicos y la arena y de
la foto y del evento con las víctimas y
en eso creo que la justicia y el sistema
integral de verdad justicia y reparación
ha venido caminando
un trabajo excelente en las para
reconocido la la verdad sin embargo yo
quiero resaltar que
para las víctimas eso es insuficiente
hoy sólo el 50 por ciento del plan de
reparación claro es entendible en área
nardy se me acaba el tiempo debo dar
paso al informativo muchas gracias por
este análisis camilo y nadie por
habernos acompañado hoy en el programa y
ustedes pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]